here's a peek at what guests had to say
after the show here on overtime
Wendell are there plans to rebuild the
Ninth Ward the white Ninth Ward is still
not rebuilt no the Ninth Ward is not
rebuild well actually just had a story
recently on how so many of the
properties that were sold back in the
road home program are still not putting
put back on Commerce I actually was
talking to someone in city government
who was a head of the one of the council
persons staff and she said that the 9th
Ward isn't viable and I asked it I said
well how many times have you been to the
Ninth Ward and discovered well I've
never been there right but you're making
decisions about whether or not is viable
to come back it's a lack of political
will it's uh it's it's political neglect
is it the poorest area is that it it is
actually I think they're trying to get
everyone to move out so then they can
expropriate all the properties because
it's right there by the river you know I
actually tried to open the store our
first door was supposed to be there if
the deal was done I'm renting the
developer is developing the store the
banker has called into a meeting with
the mayor and city hall then comes out
of the meeting who says we're not doing
it anymore
okay there's lack of political will will
be failed oh yeah we're gonna talk about
Obamacare let's do it well the failed
Obamacare rollout make America less or
more likely to adopt a single-payer
system well we don't know whether it's
failed yet I mean you know the website
obviously was a big mess
but things look a lot better than they
did a month ago don't they yes
California's signing up to 10,000 people
a day
states that aren't going through the
federal website where the governor's
actually believe in this are doing
really well and here's the deal the
people who don't have to go to the
website already win so I don't have to
go on the website I've already gotten a
rebate because Obamacare requires
insurance companies actually spend money
on medical care or rebate it to their
customers right I can i my mother gets
mammograms on Medicare my dad gets a
doughnut hole prescription drug no no
lifetime limits nope resistant
conditions my 21 year old son is a
college he's a junior in college he
stays in my past year 26 and a senior in
college
every time we liberals sorry Johnny
liberals start talking about Obamacare
it has to be said it stills gonna leave
millions without health insurance you
can still lose your insurance you can
still be you can go bankrupt still on
Obamacare it's not single-payer it's not
universal couples not gonna cover when
they're still gonna be huge holes and
people are gonna fall through it in
their lives are gonna be destroyed
because they do not have access to basic
health care that they would if they were
Canadian citizens or German citizens or
citizens of any other Western
industrialized it is every now and again
somebody invokes the specter of
socialism in this country there's not a
socialist bone in this country's body
and the moment you try and do something
wolf any other countries actually the
mana tree or socialist bone in our body
but this certainly has plenty of
socialism in our government as there
should be and you have socialism isn't a
dirty word it just means government does
some things that you wouldn't want to
trust to the private sector like life
and death it's invoke people's health by
politicians specter of all evil I mean
we all know that the bits of the
American healthcare system that people
like the ones that eighty-five percent
of the American public was pretty happy
with what they had and it was pretty
darn good public estate that's in the
world to fix what was broken truly
broken and uncovered they took a hundred
percent down and when middle-class
people and young men don't need
mammograms
they just don't and and to pay for the
numbers but were any of them have others
who do or they should have it not the
point but so we all go away but you
can't really be saying the system is
working I mean first of all we paid
twice as much as any other country with
less good result we have an awful lot of
it I come from Maryland Johns Hopkins we
have a lot of good results in this
country first of all and a lot of
Canadians down here because there ain't
too happy the two-tier or possibly even
a three-tier health care system if you
had the platinum plan yeah you had the
best health care system but you also
happen to have a whole load of people
forty million of them maybe 50 million
of them who didn't have access to good
if you just want to expand Medicaid do
it just well if I take the whole thing
seven just one to get out of the weeds
on this forum ask you one story page one
philosophical question why do you think
it is that every other advanced
democracy has come to one conclusion
which is that you cover everybody and
they all do it and we and only America
[Applause]
what today what do we know that every
other country that we would emulate
doesn't know I'm not sure William II
want to emulate a lot of those countries
first quality of care we all agree we
all agree it's just when the tens of
millions hit in January you're gonna be
in your monologue next you're gonna be
talking about jay-z peace and we trusted
them on that too when the tens another
city when the employer market hit what
when people get when employers drop
which is going to happen already be gone
and you throw your employees into the
exchange why would I have to say that
this whole group Goldberg contraption
that is Obamacare was a Heritage
Foundation plan I'll crafted by a
right-wing that's true and think tank
that is opted first by Mitt Romney
jerry ways market forces because it
wasn't a law Meritage foundation is not
Congress it was not crafted a law what
he is saying come on something ideas
sure not twenty-three hundred pages
which it was midwife's by Newt Gingrich
and then it was rated by Tom divided
Mitt Romney you know but I mean Obama's
a socialist because he wants to pass
Mitt Romney's health care system John
McCain's cap and trade bill and George
Bush's immigration bill and he's a
Marxist for health care is bad for
everybody in this country and we should
adopt the socialist single-payer model
and not this crap other countries the
countries I mean America does is books
as bill was saying you spent eighteen
percent of your GDP on health care you
ranked 37th in terms of world quality of
care you have plenty of other countries
around the world have a mixture of
public and private Germany Switzerland
Japan no socialist countries as far as I
understand that have very good health
care systems and where everybody is
covered they spend less countries all I
can say any material people get prostate
exams at Walmart I think I think there's
a little room for improvement in our
system Kaddi KYR why are we one of the
last countries to elect a female
president that's true Pakistan has
elected a female president lots lots of
other countries have had female leaders
most of them have been parliamentary
systems where the leader becomes the
leader of authority and that Shepherds
them into being the leader of the
country it is much harder in a
presidential system particularly in this
one where you have to raise doodles of
money is a polarized embedder it Ruth
cater Bader Ginsburg said it was there
are times when I feel frustrated that
American government doesn't work and
that this system is broken and in a
parliamentary system you can actually
get things
I think we need to fix the problems in
the American government system at the
moment but then you have a day like
today where we realize that elections
are gonna matter because we struck down
that ability to use the the filibuster
in a way that is just gonna be
contentious I'm sure well come back to
bite the Democrats yeah but I would I
would rather have a democratic system
where elections matter immediately
instead of a parliamentary tool that's
being used to obstruct anything that the
president is trying to do whether he's
democratic okay okay last question of
the season goes to Brad H why does it
seem like there are so few young
Democratic politicians who could
seriously compete for national office
yet the GOP has so many young stars
[Laughter]
there's pretty successful governors
right we're gonna be in the top tier for
president but but I mean as you know
with Bobby Jindal into it I mean
sometimes the Republicans do put people
out there and they think they're gonna
be a great big star and then we get a
look at them and we go whoa sure the GOP
again I mean it's like watching an
armless guy paint with his ass I would
[Applause]
remember that guy with the water that
you know I mean after steamy those look
like they're gonna be stimulus of
Obamacare and 17 trillion the American
public maybe back to a governor in hi
senator yeah good be alright thank you
very much panel thank you very much
audience Real Time with Bill Maher ask
Bill and his guests to or questions
right after the show at hbo.com